[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's bobby
back at the culture studios with a
certified geek episode now usually we
will go to somebody's house and we will
see
their complete collection their geekdom
and we're going to be amazed and we
showcase a few guys and you guys have
loved that series but we've done
something different here we've actually
brought
a collection to our studios this is
ivan's uh collection but it's not just
something that he's acquired
it's something that he's built
mask yes
mask you know what the cars that
transformed it was very similar to
transformers in a way but there's people
actually flying him and driving them
and you created this series
out of legos we've got them in sight
hold on mask we'll be right back
having said that this video is brought
to you by seeker lab ivan you're sitting
on the new titan evo right here check
this out the pillow magnetized sits on
the back of this got the new soft weave
see how comfortable it is you're
actually enjoying yourself right very
comfortable nice lumbar support check
this out real quick
these are removable gel pads nice i
don't have that on this one right okay
on yours this is pew leather 2.0 on this
so it feels almost the same as leather
but this soft weave is really
comfortable and
and
they also made a desk as well it's
called the magnus
you think about getting one
definitely all right check it out
secretly dot co
now watch what mass does
we've got a diorama here at the boulder
hill gas station we've got the figurines
we've got the vehicles
the venom and mask
uh
so yeah walk us through some of this
sure so um as you can see over here
there is the series one of the
mask toy series so in terms of mars toy
there's series one two three and four
i'm particularly uh in love with the
series one oh gee baby og all the way
original they have the rhino which is my
favorite toy
and favorite vehicle as well everybody
loves a big truck this is the first one
that i built in fact that's how i it got
me started and motivated to finish
everything
part of the reason why is because when i
grew up i never had any mass toy
you'd have a mask toy i don't have any
mustard what yeah so you did all this
without the toys yes i did this all this
without a toy i take a lot of reference
on a website as well as on youtube part
of me is that
i really see it as a challenge for
myself to make everything as accurate to
the toy as possible
and i think in terms of lego form is
also translate very nicely to all the
different vehicle forms that you know
mass universe they have of course yeah
yeah i mean was this the first thing
that you did like as an mlc creator you
did on your own
uh was mask or did you do other things
first i started with a lot of building a
lot of mecca
a lot of robots so from there on i
progress on to do do a lot more sci-fi
stuff and mars is really a coincidence
that comes out with well i've started
with rhino and then from there on i
received a lot of good comments uh and
people are telling me that oh you're
building my childhood continue to build
more they're aiming just eating me on to
build more and i also throw challenge to
myself i mean this mechanism and the
changing all these forms are not easy to
execute i mean i can't even build a lego
on my own half the time i mean you see
this lamborghini sean right here yeah
now i have one in my home right that is
the hardest damn thing to build
we got this set during uh last year
during covet right we were in a kind of
a circuit breaker in lockdown and then
we had this online conversation with the
lego technics team and we asked the guy
the creator how long did it take you to
build it goes all about eight nine hours
that took me almost about 40 hours to
build man yeah it's insane it's crazy so
the fact that
you're taking a lot of that that sort of
engineering
and you're bringing into this
how
um
especially when i when i'm talking about
the rhino build it takes about
few years to perfect the transformation
so when i first created it is it's not
like this it looks totally different
okay yeah so over the years things
improved
and with um and also with new breaks
that's being produced i'm able to uh
improve the builds according to the
bricks that's being produced as well are
you still working on it right now
apparently um i think this is pretty
accurate to the toys already okay um i
think the only only beat that i want to
improve on is probably the stripes or
unlikely to be more curvy so let's see
if they had come out with a new piece
that is more curvy i will change the
lines as well okay but now
hypothetically couldn't you um get like
bricks painted we try not to paint yeah
because
it's like a mess equation so with all
the different bricks
in place right there's always some
solutions to
each obstacle that you are facing so
if i can don't paint or if i don't like
airbrush as well as
have stickers on i try not to end to
have any uh stickers as well for this
additional enhancement on it unless it's
really necessary like the logo uh
there's nothing that you can do about it
yeah then i will have to yeah print one
come on
mask will be right back oh yes and uh
recently they have just discovered some
um a huge stockpile in mexico really yep
and this used to make a lot of those in
mexico right uh mexico hong kong and
some other places yeah so there was a
huge stockpile of donald series 3 or
series 4 that was being found and uh
they are slowly selling them off on ebay
and things like that yeah so what does
like say thunderhot go for on ebay now
um
i i i'm not tracking the prices but i
believe am i sp1
easy costs a few thousand no yeah hold
on hold on
let's see this holy
well wolf beast brand new in the box
thousand singapore dollars or best offer
about two thousand nine hundred ninety
seven dollars yeah i mean that's that's
ebay right that's they can call for
whatever price they want okay so rhino
was first yep
what was second
i believe it's the firefly okay and then
subsequently this is the printer
and i start to build the
this is the jackhammer
and then
that's when i start to post the photos
and then my friends start to notice that
i'm building masks and then it starts to
throw a challenge to me so can you build
the largest
preset available for us ah and that's
where border hill came about we got this
but what about thunderhawk that was the
cap i mean that was the
main car right yeah trans am especially
the uh model that was um based on right
it's the classic car it's a transfer
camera it was uh i think a commercial i
mean they're basically the same body
it's just pontiac and chevy basically
correct correct okay the little bit
challenge for um for thunderhawk is
always getting the shape uh especially
using lego bricks right yeah um
the the camera is a very sexy car put it
this way it is very sexy car yeah so
there's a lot of curves in front and do
you know what the famous model of that
car was
okay
series ah
um
smokey and that was the trans amber okay
in the 70s with the 80s version which
the mask was based it wasn't a camaro
but it was it was a trans black color uh
black the knight knight rider yes ah
okay yes yeah yeah that's that right
there yeah the challenge here is to get
the
doors working like yeah because you go
up right yeah it goes up so
so i'm a thunderhawk fan guys i love
thunderhawks so the door goes up yeah
and then there is this um yeah the
little cannon stack
pops out yeah the real toy okay so in
the real toy you press the button and
everything just pops
yeah but for lego that's the challenge i
can't do that there's no springs there's
no springs yeah but you can still do it
manually you can close it off you can
transform it back to a car in a car mode
but it works exactly like how
it should be or there's a particular
website called the mask force
is um
is started by a singaporean called
robert yeah and he has a lot of this
details of all the mass toys as well as
all the information they can find from
us inside this website
so bobby are you a mosque fan or are you
a venom fan
mask
because i always like thunderhawk
because i love this car okay i love this
car um condor i had i mean i had most of
the toys growing up it's obviously it's
been a number of years and i
forget the characters because i sort of
grew out of that cartoon era
you know but i had them all and i loved
it i mean it was so much fun so
my number mask uh
i would say it's mass yeah um
although
i don't really have much of a preference
yeah yeah it's it's really about the
challenge of making it into lego form
and making it accurate in terms of the
transformation okay let's talk about
transformation we're going to get to the
base in a second because i know there's
a lot to do with this one yeah but let's
talk about rhino first because i think
you're more probably most proud of rhino
huh definitely because he's also my
favorite my personal favorite okay in
the real toy there are two buttons yeah
okay so i try to mimic the two buttons
over here okay i just show you two
buttons this is the battery ram
so i think in the yeah i think in the
toy just
you just push a button and then
come yeah
yeah okay so next is that there is this
particular uh button you can place and
then the and then the seat will just pop
out okay yes it doesn't work yeah of
course okay but i make the doors open
yeah all right
okay so next will be the smoke the
chimneys yeah okay so it goes down
uh there is some some projectile coming
up in the right cartoon and things like
that which you can't do that on lego
course yeah yeah okay so next will be
the battle station
so what you do is just pull it out
and then and this is bringing you back
so many years gosh to see this in person
yeah it's all coming back to me as i'm
watching this uh transform so um that's
the battle station um
then there is this little a tv over here
ah yes yes which uh
i think one of the characters will be
sitting in and then they will do some
wrecking work
yeah we even got the goggles on him yep
no
dude check this out check out the
goggles
look at that yep
look at the details that you even got
inside the battle station here yeah this
is
from the computer the radar system oh i
added something stuff uh little uh
additional stuff inside um there's no
seat in the
original battle station yeah so i add a
seat inside yeah because i got to sit
down yeah you gotta sit down you just
can't just stand up
have you ever thought about making these
actually larger so you could do more
things with them okay so uh in terms of
skilling we always try to skew it
with the minifig scale okay okay so it
has to sit um well with the minifigs
so for example like that's why we call
this a minifig skill and for people they
know what minifigures the figurines
right the figurines yeah the lego
minifigs so
what we always try to do is to
match it with the minifig so it will be
a universal skill yeah and what we have
here with these guys okay these are
called the brakes hate um it never
happened before in mass world and i
really build it myself each one of them
will have like um they can shoot
projectiles they can do some uh special
magic movements yeah with all with the
helmets so this is the main character
and this is the main character for venom
yeah mouse mayhem
yeah so i had them as a pair and this is
the psychic miles mayhem don't you love
the names of the 80s yeah miles mayhem
very good tracker
and this is the mass logo which
never happened as a real character right
yeah
to make it yeah yes correct yeah so
let's transform this buddy right here
okay
so this is the main uh helicopter that
is piloted by miles mayhem yeah and okay
this is the
fighter jet mode and it's one of the
more challenging one because
it's a helicopter and it transforms the
jet plane okay so i'm going to transform
from the jet plane back to helicopter
mode okay cool okay so i just moved down
the
uh i think it's the stand over here and
i fold the wings
put down the back wings and then i lift
up the helicopter what i got for
is palace okay
and then
yeah yeah that's cool okay okay
how long did it take you
to get from conceptualizing it to
building i would say the conceptual
takes a longer time because i study a
lot on the real toy yeah um the other
challenge is to get the bricks into the
right color
right yeah that's gotta be tough right
uh it will take time to source for the
breaks okay i think all in all it takes
about one month to build this so one
month from sourcing to actually building
it yep that's when you are very um used
to building um yeah then it will cut
short a lot of processing time and all
that yeah mask doesn't know what it's
getting into we'll be right back
this is so much fun man i cannot believe
and i can't believe you don't have a toy
i'm still shocked you didn't buy at
least one no
i mean nowadays um
you look at the prices i know i know
yeah yeah
yeah it's it's just insane to get wise i
have a feeling they're gonna come out
with they have to come i hope so because
you know thundercats is coming back out
right in some form either it's an
animation
um you know transformers of course
everybody is bringing the nostalgia back
so you know there's got to be a mask
show i hope so that's got it
right zacky yeah i i wasn't born
gerald you were born in the 80s right
yeah but i smashed my brother's toys he
hated me
okay let's talk about the big one yeah
so this is border hill yes and it's the
headquarters of musk
so in the cartoon there is a lot of
things that's going on with this
headquarter all the time let's talk
about consistency between cartoon and
the toys this hill part
is a great brothel and uh in the cartoon
this is the maintainers area but the toy
will never happen okay so this is your
interpretation of boulder hill based on
what i can find online as well as the
toys that's available yeah i had the
opportunity to actually have the real
toy um you did yeah i said borrow from a
friend yeah he he lent me his uh border
heel and i had it side by side so that i
can have a good um gauge of the size as
well as what i need to look out for the
transformation and things like that so
it's accurate to the toy so let's start
with the um
petrol bump moves gun turrets yeah and
then
yeah and then this is the
mini mic i think the mini mud yes yeah
the supermarket station so we transform
it moves down
yeah becomes a better bunker yes this is
what it does and this is the signboard
yeah down the sideboard
you have all the little guns that rocket
launchers right yes uh yeah all the
lasers
yeah
all the fuel okay
with venomous yeah so then i would push
this out here yep and it transformed
into the
another part of the battle bunker you
see it just whoa yes do you guys gotta
see this
what how do you come up with this it
takes a lot of effort and so i was
planning to make it into a 45 degrees
angle for this i it takes me about one
month to actually do it in the right
shape and that's just this part alone
yes i have to redo it many many times
that's basically no instruction
no body has done something similar
before in this shape and i just have to
keep testing it out which is the better
way and i also need to reinforce it with
technique pieces at the back because i
when i build this i have this in mind to
be bringing it to different conventions
overseas of course you need to be sturdy
and durable
and things like that at the same time it
has to be modular i have to break it up
into different pieces by section okay so
uh yeah i survived all the uh traveling
and all that where do you show the shot
um okay so far uh the first one that it
was implant was last year but because of
cool we don't
travel and all that yeah so first show
that it will be shown is actually the
upcoming singapore fest will be
happening in october this year okay yeah
uh so you'll be showcased there
i want to order this from you yeah do
you write down and draw out all the
instructions you can provide the bricks
to the person okay so what i plan to do
is i have started a youtube channel yeah
and i'm going to
slowly uh mock central mlc cn central so
i'm going to do the build instructions
yeah on video form and people can just
follow the video and it's going to be a
long video uh
on average i think for one build small
builds it could be about seven or eight
minutes okay yeah it's not bad have you
had any orders on any of these things so
far i had a lot of requests for
instructions so how much do you sell
like let's say instruction manual for
let's say bone reveal how much would if
i want to buy it okay if you're talking
about just pure instruction i think on
the
ust thirty dollars
that's it yep
for one instruction
is this a full-time job for you no it's
not a full-time job what's full time
four times the bills i'm working in the
bank so okay yeah okay
all right that's good totally different
so it's really a way to uh yeah relax
another moy all right yeah are you
married yes very what does your wife
think of this
uh
you gotta ask that question what is
you building all this and i think
there's uh there's also this
challenge for a lot of builders like
myself um my wife is generally okay
generally okay yeah uh of course she see
that i'm doing i'm having this passion
and
she when when i know hersh i'm already
into this so oh you were yeah oh wow
okay so um pretty much like of course
it expanded and exploded over the years
this is something that i think
can go on for a long time because
there's just so much materials that you
can build
would you ever think about giving up
banking
and just becoming
a lego creator and builder it will be
something of a dream job actually let's
say if i can actually doing this full
time as well maybe
working as a youtuber in the future yeah
yeah just to
just to earn enough to support myself as
social family yeah man thank you so much
for sharing this and any other
information you want to give anybody
else watching this that might want to
get some items from you or
yeah i mean all these are part of the
my own creations that are building of
course there are other things that i do
build as well um i'll be uploading a lot
of all these on my youtube channel so do
watch out for my youtube channel and
what's going on
moc central moc central yeah all right
from there i will be sharing a lot of
instruction going forward so uh do look
out for it as well of course yeah and
you can build your own mask wow i might
just ask you to do it i'm not i'm not
that professional
but uh ivan thank you so much for coming
over here thank you culture studios
appreciate it thank you so much all
right guys with that stay safe take care
follow us on facebook subscribe to us on
youtube like this video and we'll chat
to you the next one take care okay
[Music]
you